foreign
[Music]
I'm really really happy to be here with
the lab Roots community and to tell you
some of the lessons that I've learned
over the covid pandemic and the reason
why I'm talking about these lessons is
that we can potentially apply them to
the next surge or to the next pandemic
and hopefully we'll be more prepared I'm
going to give you a lens from the
minority and vulnerable populations
perspective in addition to General
comments
so I'm a professor in the division of
infectious diseases at UCSF and during
covid
um I was privileged to take care of
hundreds of patients with covet but also
was involved in some of the clinical
trials of REM deserver and the other
anti-inflammatory drugs that we use in
patients now with covid-19 but I've also
been really impressed by how much of
society
really seeped into medicine and how much
the pandemic wasn't just about medicine
it was also about the politics that
shaped our response to it
so these are the objectives for today
um we're going to compare and contrast
the response of the covid-19 pandemic in
the United States and other developed
countries
um we'll Describe the multi-faceted
impact of the covid-19 pandemic on
diverse populations
and I want you to apply three or more
Lessons Learned to how we can respond to
Future pandemics
this is kind of a different talk it's
different from the scientific talks that
I'm used to giving uh where I'm just
really going to step back a little bit
give you a 30 000 foot View and
hopefully this will make sense to all of
you at the end of it I think we really
need to take stock of the impact of the
pandemic on all of us we haven't done
that yet we've just gone from surge to
Surge to search I think it's really
important to reflect so far on where
we've come and how remarkable our
successes are but on the other hand we
have so much more to grow too much more
to implement in terms of really creating
uh an effective response in the future
so I remember back in the early days of
the pandemic
um we felt so disconnected from our
patients and
one way in which some of us dealt with
this was really by putting out pictures
um
in my little ID badge that I will hand
out to patients because again
we were so afraid to go into these rooms
we were so afraid of getting covet and
we were losing that human touch there
was so many of my older patients who
were dying alone only surrounded by that
you know one-on-one-off Medical
Professional would be there in the room
with them but FaceTime and all of that
was really only in its infancy and it
was really really difficult for many
people
so why am I talking to you about equity
and that lens on covid well I come from
uh Caribbean island Trinidad and Tobago
it's the most southerly island in the
Caribbean chain right off the coast of
Venezuela and
um when I grew up my in a village shop
in this Village my parents were my role
models and they really modeled
um you know treating everyone fairly and
kindly and when people didn't have
resources to get groceries to give it to
them they'll deliver groceries for free
they taught people the right uh all this
really shaped my view towards medicine
and health and equity
so I eventually went to Brown University
and
um was lucky enough to come to San
Francisco uh fall in love with it and
decided that this would be the place for
me to do medical training
so I did a residency in Internal
Medicine after medical school and
specialized in infectious diseases I
worked initially in HIV again this was
my introduction to equity and healthcare
because there were all these people
coming around the table uh really giving
input on the health of our patients and
it wasn't just the HIV medicines or or
the diabetes or the hypercholesterolemia
it was the the fact of whether or not
they had good housing whether or not uh
they could get to the clinic to their
appointments how much loss they've
experienced all of these things shape
People's Health and it was very very
apparent to me that Health wasn't just
about that medicine that we gave to
people or that diagnostic test that we
were able to utilize for the patients
so right now in my career I'm lucky to
be the associate Dean for regional
campuses and what that means is
you know I've always been involved in
pipeline work so preparing the next
generation of uh the scientific
Workforce uh a diverse population that
asks questions uh in science that's
derived from the communities from which
uh the investigators come from
so um through work and funding from the
NIH we were able to uh pilot and uh you
know Implement some of these programs
partnering UCSF with uh some of the
community colleges state colleges Etc to
really pave that pathway for scientists
so this is SF build where we're really
building that next PhD Workforce but
there are also other pipeline programs
I've done uh in specifically in the
Health Professions and medicine like
this one now where we're trying to
build the workforce in the Central
Valley which has one of the poorest
outcomes in terms of health outcomes in
the country very similar to Appalachia
or the U.S Mexico border so I think
exclusive growth and we really need
these Healthcare Professionals for the
future so that's kind of where I'm at
and why I'm interested in this area and
having taken care of again of all of
these covet patients during the last
three years haven't engaged with the
community doing a lot of Community
Education Grassroots activities as as
I'll tell you about
I've really been able to reflect on
where we've come as a community where
we've come as a country during these
past two years
so lesson number one
Health equals politics and politics
equals health
so I think this is
no better exemplified by the ways that
we think about masking which to me as a
physician
really really is strange because I think
in medicine we've used Maps
forever for decades and decades in the
surgical room in in fact a symbol or
metaphor
for a physician or Healthcare
professional is that mask in the OR
think of all the TV shows you've seen so
when we think about the infusion of
politics into wearing a mask it really
is astonishing uh to me and um I think
part of it was uh the mixed messaging
that occurred uh particularly early on
in the pandemic and throughout the
pandemic where initially uh the future
General said you don't have a wear mask
and then everyone said CDC you have to
wear a mask
uh it was confusing to people in the
community and of course one thing we've
learned
Sciences updated constantly every hour
there's something new about some topic
that I thought I knew really well
but masking has become more than health
it's become politics it's become a way
in which we Define our political
standing and I think that's really
really uh sad uh because at the end of
the day it is a barrier and it is a risk
mitigation strategy that it's not the
be-all and end-all but it is one in
which uh we can help protect ourselves
and our communities even more and when
you look at at masking behavior
um
in different communities in the United
States you can see that there's a big
divide uh based on uh political
affiliation
and because of this lack of alignment of
Science and politics because of the the
lack of a national strategy early on in
the pandemic I think it's it's no
surprise just like infant mortality and
maternal uh deaths that the U.S is uh
has the highest rates of cumulative
death throughout the pandemic when you
look at contemporary countries and this
is you know per hundred thousand
um and this even you'd say well maybe
this was just maybe in the beginning of
the pandemic and after we got our act
together things got better but you can
see on the graph on the right that even
during the umicron uh wave that uh
deaths are still uh per hundred thousand
the highest in the developed world and
when you look at the other countries
that we're comparing ourselves to
Belgium Britain France Sweden Germany
Netherlands Canada Japan Australia
it's really shocking that uh we despite
spending all these billions of dollars
in operation warp speed and in the covet
emergency response that we're still at
the top of the deaths per hundred
thousand in the developed world and
again it really speaks to lack of
alignment of Science and politics it
speaks to lack of a national strategy
early on particularly when you compare
it to other countries that had all of
these things New Zealand Taiwan uh
Germany early on Etc you can see that
we're very much in contrast to that so
number one lesson science is politics
and politics uh is health
so I was mentioning that uh
masking is affiliate uh has a political
affiliation uh and it's really
interesting when you look at the deaths
in the US linked to political
affiliation where
um people at either voted for
um one party or the other in the last
election that there is a really strong
uh association with the covet deaths per
hundred thousand and and who you voted
for and again that really is a stark
reminder that you can't really
disentangle the politics from the health
uh despite throwing a lot of financial
resources at it
to lesson number two
um
working fast is really important uh in a
pandemic and it requires agility strong
communication and alignment
I think for this lesson to me it was
really looking at what we did with
diagnostic testing and this audience in
lab routes knows well the importance of
diagnostic testing and the importance of
the laboratory in that crucial arm of
not only diagnosis but prevention as
well because knowledge is power and when
you know that you're positive with covet
particularly early on when we didn't
have any treatment options it was really
important to do contact tracing and that
diagnostic test was the Cornerstone of
all of that so one could imagine that if
we had testing earlier that we could
have probably saved uh lots of lives but
unfortunately due to a lot of missteps
we
we didn't have the testing as the
audience as well early on in the
pandemic it was already developed by wh
to it agreed to
give the testing know how to United
States and tests but we wanted to do it
on our own and unfortunately that led to
a lot of delays so early on in the
pandemic what I remember is that we were
just testing people who we knew already
kind of already had covet and we were
not testing the Seas of people who were
already infected before they began to
transmit infection and didn't know they
were infected so to give you an analogy
it's almost like if you were
only diagnosing people with HIV
infection when they had end-stage
disease like corporate sarcoma or PC
pneumonia but not diagnosing people
early on and these people were then
transmitting it to lots of other people
not because they were being deceitful or
or
bad they were just not knowing that they
were positive so again knowledge is
power and there's so many Echoes between
the HIV pandemic and where we were in
covid so this delaying testing uh
eventually it came on board uh but then
disparities began to emerge very very
clearly because getting a test was
almost like you have to know somebody
who kind of got you an appointment early
on it was such a limited resource
um and uh access to test was really a
big deal and probably that set the stage
for really uh having these pronounced
disparities that we saw in covid not
only in infections but in symptomatic
infections hospitalizations and most
importantly deaths because these are
lies that will never get back from the
almost 1 million American deaths so far
in the pandemic
uh lesson number three heat is a virus
so like I mentioned there's so many
analogies between covid-19 and HIV
pandemic in so many ways there's the
other there's the use of kung flu or
China virus uh there's a hate that
really emerged and in The Firestorm
during covet and it's still going on
and
um you know I think what drives a lot of
heat is anxiety and that leads leads to
people thinking about the other
um and and siloing in society and and
this was really really prominent during
the covid-19 pandemic and still going on
like I mentioned
so um as the audience know there's been
a lot of uh increase in hate crimes
particularly against Asian Americans in
fact the center for study of heat
and extremism showed an increase in uh
359 percent in anti-asian hate crimes
between 2020 and 2021
and then there was a further increase so
this was a a higher increase than the
increase between 2019 and 2020. so again
what was really
um
depressing about the pandemic was that
year one seemed to be bad and we began
to get Technologies and began to have a
bigger understanding scientifically of
the pandemic but year two in 2021 seemed
to be even worse even though we had
these tools at hand and I think hate was
one of these uh issues so in terms of
where was each anti-asian heat well it
was in the big cities for sure uh that
were most affected New York La San
Francisco where I live
but the interesting fact is that black
Americans Remain the most targeted in
most cities from this uh study and
really speaks the underlying heat that
drives a lot of um how we operate in
society and to me as a healthcare
professional ultimately affects People's
Health that's why I think it's really
crucial that we as scientists Embrace
this I know a lot of you already have
but that we continue to embrace these
Concepts and actively act uh as
upstanders for people in our communities
so I wanted to quote uh one
um
food from John Yang from the Asian
Americans Advantage dressing Justice
Group which says that especially during
a time when groups are trying to divide
into vulnerable communities against each
other we must remember that we are
stronger together so no matter where you
come from I think in science we know
that diversity leads to better science
I think this understanding and tolerance
leads to Better Health as well leads to
using fewer Hospital resources uh so you
get a lot of good for doing good
so lesson number four uh protest is a
valid Public Health response even in the
middle of a pandemic so what am I
talking about
so everyone knew that in or remembers
that in the summer of uh 2019 there was
the George Floyd protests and
I think that
um
we we were really struck by
um I'm sorry summer of 2020. we're
really struck by
how much this galvanized the community
galvanized uh society and
um I remember this was in the middle of
the pandemic and uh people were saying
well should we really allow protests or
condone protests happening from a health
science perspective because
aren't we all supposed to be Sheltering
in place at this time uh and the last
thing you'd want to do for virus
Transmissions perspective is have a lot
of people move around with
um includes quarters being very
emotional
but again coming back to my thinking
that um
inequities and structural racism causes
poor health and there's tons of evidence
as this audience knows to support that
then protesting is a valid Public Health
response because it impacts health
so the way we did it was that and I was
involved in writing a petition and and
and circulating it and getting people to
come on board what we did was really
tell people
you can definitely protest in fact it's
important to protests but in but
protests uh safely so we wrote a list of
ways in which people can protest safely
including you know wearing masks and
most of the people during the George
Floyd protest we're wearing masks
um
uh having giving guidance to uh police
and other armed forces in terms of not
questing people in include spaces
um having a little bit of distance
between them
um and providing all the risk mitigation
strategies as we knew at the time uh you
know
for hand sanitizers masks Etc so I think
all of this harm reduction led to not
many uh Transmissions actually in these
George Floyd protests when you look at
the data um and there have been several
cities that have published um
population-based data uh at the time
another way that uh I think we in the
scientific Community were also involved
during
uh this time is around tear gas so uh at
the time of protests even though tear
gas has been
in international Warfare was still
allowed
domestically which I personally think is
is really a travesty and and really
doesn't make any sense and for many
years people have tried to say please
don't use tear gas but I think using the
science as a way to
have people understand that it wasn't a
good idea you know if they didn't really
think about the human rights aspects
because once you use tear gas it makes
you cough and uh your eyes water and
you're rubbing your face
so if we think about tear gas as
increasing people's susceptibility to
infection because they're all it's also
inflaming the Airways and the nasal
passages to make it easier for covet to
have uh setup shop basically and cause
infections as well as increases risk of
transmission to other people if that
person had covet they didn't know it and
you sprayed tear gas on them they'll be
shouting and screaming uh and yelling
and of course we know all of that
behavior increases uh transmission
potential for covid so I think by
highlighting why tear gas wasn't good
from a coveted and scientific
perspective in terms of both
infection transmission as well as
susceptibility I think it allows people
to at least listen to that dialogue and
in some some communities at least
locally they were able to ban tear gas
which I was really happy about
even though uh not necessarily uh in all
places but I think what it taught me is
that first of all it's okay to protest
fruit that safely
if it affects Health outcomes and then
you can try to highlight some of the the
dangerous aspects that I use to disputes
crowds by using science to help you do
that to polity Makers
uh lesson number five
um engaging with the community is really
important but not to treat minority
populations as one so it's not like the
majority in the minority all in
California where I live uh it's in many
communities there is no majority anymore
but every Community is its own uh group
and you have to tailor make your message
towards that group you have to tailor
make your interventions towards specific
groups using specific strategies
so I asked Christian Captain
um one of the news reporters from San
Francisco to really give us insight
about treating each Community separately
hi my name is Christian kaft and I'm a
television reporter for a KTVU Channel 2
news in the San Francisco Bay area and
certainly one of the interesting aspects
of covering covid-19 was seeing how it
impacted various communities differently
certainly for our black communities
there seemed to be a general sense of
mistrust of a lot of medical
institutions and a lot of vaccine
hesitancy as specifically in San
Francisco again some of that is
understandable certainly considering the
complex history that African-Americans
have with medical institutions one of
the issues that was cited repeatedly of
course were the Tuskegee experiment
starting in the 1930s for our Latino
populations we noticed that they had a
very high rate of covid-19 when compared
to other ethnic groups in the Bay Area
and part of that is due to a whole host
of socio-economic reasons including the
fact that a lot of our Latino
populations in the San Francisco Bay
Area live in more highly dense
neighborhoods a lot of them were working
in essential positions so had to
continue working through the pandemic
and some of them still relying on using
public transportation to get to and from
those jobs and then possibly bringing
covid back to their families so these
are some of the issues that we're facing
are at latinx and Latino populations and
of course San Francisco has a large
Asian American population specifically
in San Francisco a large monolingual
Cantonese speaking Community making sure
that they were aware of covid-19 wasn't
the big issue a lot of them seem to be
very aware that kova 19 was an issue but
making sure that they were aware of the
very latest medical advisories medical
orders and and quarantine orders those
types of issues making sure that they
were aware of a lot of that Nuance was
difficult because a lot of the
information was given out in English and
then had to be translated into Cantonese
so that was one of the difficulties
there in learning how to do all of that
so some of the lessons that we learned
in the media was that we have to treat
each Community somewhat differently and
respect the differences of those
communities make sure that we can
communicate with them in a way that they
feel comfortable we can't fall into the
Trap of treating any Community as a
monolith either so just because it's an
African-American Community or a Latino
Community or a cantonese-speaking
community we can't treat them as
individuals we have to treat them as
individuals rather we can't treat them
as a monolith and have to realize that
we have to speak to each person
individually and understand that they
can take information as a whole
now of course being in the media I have
a bias towards communication but I was
able to work closely with lots of
medical professionals throughout the
pandemic and making sure that we were
able to try to get good quality
information to uh various people and
everybody really throughout the pandemic
and so that would enable them then to
make the best decisions about what to do
for themselves and for their families
and that was one of the critical
elements is trying to work on that
relationship and make sure that that
communication between the medical
community and the various communities
around the Bay Area was as clear as
possible I certainly hope that this
information is helpful to you as you go
on helping others thank you
thanks a lot uh Christian
um so lesson number six communication is
key as Christian said I think it's
important for all of us to know that
there's no need to be an expert all of
you in the lab Roots uh audience so far
is an expert already and you there's no
need to stay in your lane when it comes
to clear communication and communicating
science to the general Community you
want to align science and politics and
use empathy
so I asked uh Greg leggings to speak
about
one thing I learned during the pandemic
as it relates to minority communities is
this prevalence of vaccine hesitancy I
saw this across age gender even to a
certain degree income lines
I think there are at least two reasons
behind that one would be the historical
wrongs done to some minority communities
I'm referring of course things like the
Tuskegee experiment that people heard
about and they just ran with that
information and then also the
inconsistent and oftentimes
contradictory messaging coming to us on
both a national and local level
I'm not necessarily talking about the
vaccine itself but things like mask
wearing what you could and couldn't do
indoors and Outdoors that messaging was
just very inconsistent and really
confused a lot of people
thanks Greg I probably wouldn't have
much more to add to eloquence already
lesson number seven disparities amplify
during a pandemic and like I mentioned
we thought 2020 was bad but 2021 was
even worse and after two years of this
priority this still exists you can't
really see the graph that easily on the
left side but it really shows that um
um many minority populations have at
least twice if not more the odds of
being hospitalized and dying and
discontinued during uh the pandemic and
not really abated in fact when you look
at kids and hospitalization minority
kids during the the surges have had a
four times higher hospitalization rates
than the general public population and
like I mentioned throughout this talk
there's so many disparities that still
persist for many minority populations
um and and and I think being aware of
that can help us from the next pandemic
I think one place in which I'm seeing
this happen right now is with Park fluid
at people in the audience to impactful
it is an oral therapy given for covid
it's used to shut down the virus Factory
um by targeting early virus production
before the body gets angry and that's
the inflammatory response so it's taken
within three days it gives uh it reduces
the risk of hospitalization vulnerable
folks with comorbidities by 89 three
pills twice a day for five days you
watch out for drug interactions but as
we see it play out in the country so far
uh even though there's a test and Street
program with the pandemic response and
the strategy I think and I'll quote from
this article the community statistically
most likely to need the services that
are to be offered on the website are
also the communities that are
statistically most unlikely to be able
to access it in other words this
actually increase in equity so I'm
hoping in crossing fingers that we
really pay attention to not just having
the program but the devil is always in
the details in terms of having people
have easy access and knowledge about Pax
loaded a lesson eight pandemics at
syndemics just briefly stating that the
more epidemics that you have you add
another epidemic or pandemic on top of
it and the sum of its parts is worse
than individually for example the
epidemic or pandemic of covid the
epidemic or pandemic of HIV you add
poverty and structural racism and the
sum of these thoughts are much more than
the individual components themselves
lesson nine Money Talks we know this
really well because the emergency
response dollars are still being
questioned by Congress and if you know
we don't want to be in an emergency
response but like somebody said to me
don't always wish
um put something that you'll get because
what it means is that there'll be no
longer funding potentially for things
that we take for granted like
Diagnostics and testing and drugs so I
think uh all of this really needs to
continue funding
um you know for us to really even get
over this current pandemic
uh but I'd like to end on a on a high
note which is that the future is bright
and training the Next Generation like
many of you listening to this requires a
coordinated and sustained push and I
think that that's been really fulfilling
for me uh in my career so far uh during
the pandemic it's training and enabling
the next generation of folks to to
really do the communication
uh do be my own do my own health care in
the future
take care of me during the next pandemic
and I think there is a lot of Hope in
the new generation that would not only
learn laboratory science or public
health but be able to integrate all of
these things together uh rather than us
living in silos even though I do
understand there's a need for specialty
I think when there's an emergency
response there's all hands on deck and
we all become communicators
so on the other Silver Lining I think
after talking to people over and over
again they do change their minds people
who are vaccine has then become vaccine
hesitant uh We've developed a lot of
science the vaccine is a Wonder in terms
of the speed and the deployment
um uh over time so I asked Charles Hurd
another reporter to give an Insight of
where we are right now in terms of covid
and minority populations
hi I'm Cheryl heard with NBC bay area
it's been really tough covering this
pandemic for the past two years in the
very beginning people of color really
apprehensive about getting the shot now
two years later folks of color are
getting it even my nieces and nephews
people I never thought would do it
well we've come to the end and I hope at
least you use these lessons that I've
learned personally to reflect on where
we've come so far and uh where we are
going in the future and I think all of
you as scientists as Healthcare
professionals as Learners we all have a
part to play and
um I think really we will weather the
next pandemic hopefully much better than
we have with this one thank you